madame philippe de faire entrer le
deuxième masse clover on a une deuxième
surprise pour quelqu'un autour de la
table je vous le dis j'ai été très très
très étonné de devoir faire appel à
cette personne je n'ai rien vu arriver
tout comme vous chez vous vous n'avez
certainement rien pourtant regardez le
premier indice
c'est vous qu'on puisse avoir le coup de
foudre en direct à la télévision est-ce
que vous pensez que l'un d'entre vous
ici que le coup de foudre en direct à la
télé jean-louis wiki pas moi benjamin
benjamin oui avec boîte mode famille
mais je vous parle dernièrement mais moi
je pose des questions on n'a rien vu en
tout cas si haga a par jamie d'artichaut
c'est vrai que je me suis assez sensible
donc c'est vrai que je suis célibataire
et je peux tomber très vite amoureux
mais et pour ça avec une idée bien car
il n'a pas tort cette dame c'est la vie
ça sera mise bas me réveille toi il est
temps pour votre mari vous avez au coup
de fouet
vous l'avez vu jouer vous l'avez vu
comme ça pas si canon je vais pas me
jouer moi vous voulez vous
non je n'ai rencontré sur snapshot nom
fort à lui aussi la rencontre et sa meuf
sur ce match at elle avait amassé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une boîte à chatou les chéris regardez
le 2-0 pas selon vous l'amour et la
politique sont compatibles propos pour
moi au fond est-ce que selon vous la
voir et la politique sont compatibles
ouais ouais ouais tu me dire voilà une
fois de plus ce masque lover vous
concerne
il ya quelque chose qui est ce que je l'
ai vu que j'ai vu c'est vrai il ya
l'esclave est déjà le même pantalon
j'arrive si j'arrive avec la personne
c'est roselyne bachelot voix l'artichaut
a trouvé sa vinaigrette l'artichaut est
ce que weeds qui je parlais je crois que
cette semaine vous avez eu un coup de
foudre pour quelqu'un qui est venu nous
rendre visite dans touche pas vous qui
êtes avec nous bien sûr michel mr a eu
un coup de foudre pour quelqu'un oui je
vais vous montrer des images et la
personne viendra nous rejoindre juste
après à vous allez voir jean-michel il
est quand même terrible ouais je ne vais
plus à amener d'invités lors de l'achat
et bien entendu on va voir si c'est bien
la personne qui est venu nous voir et
elle vous donnera sa réponse en direct
c'est oui s'il vient c'est oui je pense
que j'avais mes fils parfois le serveur
amène le mauvais plat
[Musique]
pour moi c'est génial ballons volés il
adore le ballon je l'échangé
[Musique]
youpi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas ces choses et de belles choses
ce soir un bon match je chéris qui
coanime avec moi je me régale avec toi
mais moi si mon bébé je prenne le temps
mais ça veut dire que si par hasard ça
se fait il varie va pas taire sur btp
lui non levallois partir tout simplement
alors elle valoir
je voudrais remercier je vais députés
laurence baudet adjointe au maire de
levallois au service des sports et
belleville être avec nous ce soir
c'est vrai qu'au printemps michel parce
que laurence bourdes et elle est
magnifique c'est très très laurence
bourdais est belle laurence bourdais est
intelligente
laurence bourdais et souriante l'ordre
aux bourdes et sympathique mais laurence
bourdais et marié aimée telle venue
qu'est ce qu'elle a elle est mariée et a
détaillé bible je n'ai rien entendu
ça c'est la douche froide laurange
bourdais vous êtes venu vous vous êtes
mariés oui je voudrais lui témoigner
derrière ce sera utile pour la peine on
attend déjà les médecins les médecins et
sauve des vies massif et benji et je
voulais lui dire ce soir que je laime
beaucoup aux jeunes éminent au premier
que sa lettre la soirée de l'amour pour
l'instant fatou qui n'appelle pas il
prend une banale en direct du cauchemar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis content alors heureuse est
magnifique vous aviez vraiment craqué
pour l'eau et j'ai craqué pour elle mais
je suis ravi de savoir qui elle est très
heureuse dans son couple évidemment là
que personne avait craqué pour moi je
suis pas aussi je suis agent secret oui
ça m'a fait vraiment plaisir sa matrice
et les combattants 15 ans n'en tiendra
aussi une question bien sûr et vous
n'êtes pas du tout aux couples est libre
à battice noyalo je sais pas moi non
mais je vais vous poser une question qui
me vient d'exclure se pose bien entendu
que nous sommes en direct sourire c'est
l'amour et l'amour et parfois dangereux
ou faux benger art ou art ou direct
laurence ouais si rennes est ce que par
l'opération du saint-esprit
ou bien tu nous étions d'oran dans la
fiction ouais
et bizarrement du jour au lendemain vous
retrouver célibataire mais heureuse dans
ma carrière parce que voilà vous avez
envie d'être libre free free dom
président sans sucre peuvent avec calme
toi toi tu étais enfant moi et pas de
conneries la désinfo sur son mari non
non pas du tout répond pas aux codes de
son mari va très bien orienté on ne
connaît pas mon ibook très bien lancé ce
que jean-michel aurait pu être votre
style un tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
laurence et bien écoutez
merci là c'est comme s'il ya quelqu'un
qui vient de te dire il à te dire écoute
tu sais quoi
tu avais des bons numéros du loto mon
affaire du week-end
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les séries est très gentil devenu hassan
abou ouais ça c'est une femme comme ça
qui joue pourtant qu'elle soit heureuse
c'est une femme comme ça qui donne la
vraie nature non messieurs les classes
de caractère comme ça avec une une
vahiné dit quelque chose à l'écran
non mais c'est vrai du croquant à la
dengue ou à la du crotoy nous